dans les temps anciens les mongols
vénérait les heureuses élues mais avec
le don de comprendre les chevaux grand
père on n'est pas dans un conte de fées
c'est quoi ça ne vous look en mode
halloween ou quoi je suis vraiment nuls
9 sur 20 c'est pas la cata mes vieux
vent me sucrer mes vacances quoi tu ne
nous laisse pas le choix tu passeras
l'été avec ta grand-mère quoi au
cimetière nantes un autre grand mère
alors oui car il paraît qu'on s'écarte
du droit chemin
tu as quel niveau james et jm jamais
monter à cheval
profitant d'un séjour à l'heure
mika est entré dans le box et s'est
endormie donc celui de wii sports ce
cheval est dangereux il ne se laisse
monter par personne je ne veux surtout
pas qu'elle se balade dans le haras sans
surveillance oui entendu ah non
archibald est tombé amoureux d'une vache
lucas est en symbiose avec sochaux mais
ne s'était jamais intéressé aux chevaux
avant whisper est en partie c'est pas
vrai elle s'est liée à ce cheval très
peu de personnes ont ce don je sais je
vous ai souvent déçu mais là je sens que
j'ai trouvé ma voie et cie ont participé
au tournoi
personne ne peut apprendre à monter à
cheval ont un mode carrière sissi prête
avant de monter à cheval il faut
maîtriser trois piliers équilibre le
rythme et la coordination et le
quatrième le quatrième quel quatrième la
persévérance
je n'ai jamais vu une telle capacité à
communiquer avec un cheval
tu es prête à quoi à faire ce dont tu
rêves depuis toujours volet wii sports
comment ça drôle de dégaine tu te
permets